we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's something kind of
funny
so we launched the David Pacman show
Finance Channel and I I've mentioned
this before you can find it at
youtube.com
Pacman Finance it's no politics it's
just basic personal finance uh education
and advice and it's not specific advice
it's just general concepts that are
important to understand we're already
almost at 10 000 subscribers it is seems
to be striking a nerve last week I
showed a message from a viewer who said
what are my credentials to even talk
about this and I said well I have an MBA
specializing in financial planning those
are my credentials and it's not like a
humble brag it's just someone said what
are your credentials those are my
credentials and here is a caller who
says no no no no that's not enough
hey David
um you know I recently watched your
video on your main YouTube channels
talking about you know
um how exactly you're qualified to talk
financial matters and you said because
you had an MBA or qualified to talk on
financial matters right well David let
me guess something straight dude and NPA
does not make you qualified to talk on
financial matters okay come back when
you have a PhD or something like really
special okay David I mean get a freaking
grip dude just because you have an MBA
doesn't mean you're qualified to speak
on financial lives in fact I think the
most prudent Financial advice comes from
Dave Ramsey David you know what Dave
Ramsey has
not an MBA [ __ ]
yeah well Dave Ramsey does have a
bachelor's degree so that is something
yeah listen to be totally honest
there's people who know a ton about
personal finance and don't have any
degree in it it's actually it was sort
of like a joke
um it reminds me of some discussion we
were looking at where someone said to an
economist what qualifies you to give uh
economic uh analysis anyway and the
guy's like well I have a PhD in
economics
um it's you know we've talked about the
appeal to Authority
and the appeal to expertise's potential
cognitive biases or logical fallacies
rather not cognitive biases and the
truth is I I don't even really subscribe
to what I said which is like I know
about this stuff because of my degree
because quite frankly most of the stuff
you learn by doing and you learn by by
individual research and learning but
anyway I encourage you check out the
finance Channel subscribe for free
totally different thing the way I
describe it is
it's like Dave Ramsey without the right
wing nuttery without the Christian
messaging and without the anti-vaxx
that's the idea of the Pacman Finance
Channel youtube.com pacmanfinance we've
got a great bonus show for you today Joe
Biden is warning oil industry uh
companies as hurricane Ian has made
landfall in Florida and Joe Biden is
saying do not gouge the American people
on gas we will see if they will heed his
warning Joe Biden has also approved an
additional billion plus dollars in
security assistance to Ukraine are
Republicans in favor of or against this
because remember it was Biden didn't do
enough for Ukraine and also there's too
much money going there
wait so how could it be both and Donald
Trump is seeking to end his rape
accusers defamation lawsuit is this
finally going to be the end of the road
for that lawsuit or not all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com use the coupon
code indict to get yourself a discount
and we will see you then when I am
joined by producer Pat by the way
a lot of people writing in and saying
David what is up with that bruise on
producer Pat's nose he explains it on
the bonus show this week he explains
what happened to his nose so please tune
in join pacman.com we'll see you on the
bonus show